at the SPS and I did this bring some
football memories back for you know what
this is my first time at the ESPYs whoo
who would have known I would have got
here through bachelor and football no
I'm super honored to be here there's so
many cool people so it's gonna be fun
night all right my friend well I gotta
get your thoughts on some bachelor
related things we just saw hometowns and
we were watching Jed's family basically
say that they didn't want him to be with
Hanna what was your reaction to seeing
those conversations well I think if
there is any doubt about the whole
conspiracy theory and sort of the drama
going on with Jed it was put to rest and
sort of confirmed just with that
hometown because you could see something
wasn't really right or they were sort of
biting their lips for some things so it
was a little fishy it was a little
awkward awkward I mean I just
interviewed Ben Higgins the other day
and Ben said I don't think Jed can come
back from this scandal where do you
think that Stan shouldn't come back from
this and he should just sort of go away
but you know I think what's sort of been
eye-opening to me because I follow on
social media I love Twitter and every
once in a while firing back at people
but being in the position hand has been
before you sort of have these blinders
on and you're sort of dialed in and
focused on the relationship and you
don't take in sort of the cues that
sometimes you should in regular
relationships or the red flag so I feel
for her because she's so deserving of
somebody who is gonna make her happy day
in and day out and not have to worry
about lying so by the way I saw you and
Kass got in a vacation that had to feel
good oh my gosh we were so excited to
get to Bermuda is our first vacation
where we really didn't do anything other
than just like drink and lay on a beach
no one was filming you nobody was
filming us
so we got a snorkel and stuff it's been
it was it was much needed she's just
started back up with her internship in
her schooling for the fall so I'm so so
proud of her and she saw she I mean what
she does and balances everything it's
very impressive gotta ask you yes is
Hanna's fence the windmill
[Music]
thank you Tom talk about a bomb getting
dropped I'm here for all of it I know
it's sort of like polar opposite of like
what my take on my season was but I
think that's what's so cool about The
Bachelor franchise is everybody has
their own their own twist of things i
polar opposite do you mean your thing
was a virgin now we've got yes sex
anyone no yeah I said you either get
scrutinized for not having sex or
scrutinize driving too much there's no
middle ground I mean did your job do you
think people's jaws dropped more with
you jump in the fence or when that
window reveal happened I think it was
just you know two completely different
things but you know if that's what she
was feeling was necessary for that
relationship and that's what I'm glad
that she got to do it because sometimes
with the you know with the show you get
your sort of hands tight a little bit
with the format of the show and I'm glad
to see that the format is sort of going
away let's just let these relationships
be what they are last question I asked
you this before and you picked Peter has
your pick for bachelor changed at all a
couple episodes later what after
following social media I still like
Peter and I still want Peter to be
bachelor Chris Cassidy he was cute so
like let's get him off the market but
Tyler has a lot of the qualities that a
bachelor needs or whatever whatever you
want to quote unquote think the bachelor
but you know what the cool thing is is
you never know what flex is going to do
so we'll see
[Music]